I was in the Navy for 26 years and I was
a hospital corpsman here's a great
opportunity for veterans I mean I know
you raised your right hand and you swore
to defend the Constitution against all
enemies foreign and domestic would you
like to know what that really meant
would you like to know those source
documents to federalist papers and read
those and understand what it means to be
an American and defend our Constitution
and and get an education that will
propel you forward your GI Bill is very
valuable and there are a lot of people
out there who love to take it but you're
coming to an institution that won't take
it in fact we're going to supplement
your GI bill with money from Americans
who believe in Liberty in the
Constitution and they want you to have
this awesome education what why would
you not want that
when you leave the military you go to
the transition assistance office and
they let you know to try to bring you
back into the civilian world we know how
those civilians can be well here the
transition is also something that you
have to go through and so we have
provided opportunity for you to
transition we have like a dorm that we
have been housing to my veterans we call
it fort awesome and it's awesome we hook
you up with an advisor that was prior
military you come and talk to me you
know I was in the Navy I understand
about transitioning so we work with you
to make that smooth this is a great
opportunity so jump on it